remember that controversial peloton ad  that was criticized for being sexist yes  okay so you guys will remember that many  did not like the way showed a man giving  his wife of teletón exercise bike for  the holidays well now the actor who  played the husband his name is Shawn  hunter is turning his role into reality  he gave his real-life girlfriend a  peloton good for him for Christmas and  posted this photo on Instagram saying  here's hoping this goes over better the  second time she wants the peloton it's  great I'm Yael I thought there was way  too much made over that that was very  strongly yeah and the camp that says  look not a big relax yeah relax a lot  pretty cool but is it funny ironic that  he would give his girlfriend  I wonder if peloton helped out with that  maybe you wonder yeah wonder Dana  you